something's you two boxes that's all you
need
[Music]
fine it's gonna be one of those nights
[__] if you hear that banging in
a Dodger bat it's your [__] head we
got the good stars tonight they're nice
and old they're harder than [__] you eat
10 of those things your job break but
who gives a [__] at least you'll be
given in the hospital drinking that
[__] milkshake and I'm saying if
you're under 18 hang up now [__]
welcome to the Voodoo Lounge where
dreams become realities many men have
walked in and they've walked out cowards
from a little red star don't let that
happen to you [__] we got the goods
today oh [__]
you thought well [__] around tonight
look at this look at this ladies four
aces with his four aces by we're going
heavy and we got the red ones but
they're harder than [__] and we got
[__] up the end I got him to pee in
the middle night I saw purple streaks
this [__] we need everything we need
everything we can get every man for
himself nobody knows what they need
until they need it you follow me nobody
knows what they need until they need it
you know said that Johnny fingers 155th
Street nobody knows what they need till
they need it and that's it and that's
that [__] break
are you bad [__] uncle Joey had
a Wednesday night reporting live from
the Voodoo Lounge the [__] doors
we got reefer we got edibles we got
nothing but heart and balls we don't
give a [__] what anybody thinking it's a
wit thinking [__] how you like
then news huh the ice house is sold out
this weekend so I don't know what to
tell you you're gonna have to come to
Omaha Nebraska next week and rocked it
up up there at the funny bone or New
York City got them with Dean Dell rizzi
for the New York Comedy Festival ron
wyden bunch of his [__] savages will
be there but without further ado let me
show you the guest tonight we got insane
over here look at this [__] thing
when you gonna get it
a container we like this you come see me
look at these [__] things look oh
Jesus focus focus dominocus we got the
leftover of the classic with fingernails
and everything that's how I roll and
then we got these [__] here
look at this look at this and we got
these stars that are harder than [__]
tremendous you understand me by now
they're starting to get moldy that's
when I get good you eat 10 of these
things wrong and you're so kitchen Hey
oh yeah well don't look deep until the
deep I'm just fearful man
[Music]
who the [__] do you think you're dealing
with this is this is it this is it
you asked for it you got it
[__] you know not you I'm
talking to you right you don't need to
ask for nothing you just see what they
give you [__]
all right you owe me this like a jail
would you just eat what they give you
just like this look at your pop-up a
pound you rip this thing open break on
little it looks like one of those
pimples that comes on a Chinese woman
you know ones that pop people's temples
on their neck this came out of Jerry
Garcia's neck look at it it's a [__]
[Music]
look at this gun you understand me like
a snake I'll let the intestines [__] and
break that [__]
look at leaves up to his first dog I'm
up to my last [__] ten more stars
that's the least of my problems I eat
him while I'm [__] just hanging out
like got a pirate thief you over there
making faces sweating breathing heavy
spots are coming up like this she was a
Chinese woman when she pops a pimple she
grabs all those dirty white people by
the neck and she squeezes cuz it's
always dirty white people we don't see
brothers showing up with a way that on
their neck and I'm saying they get
blackheads on their next big difference
look at this look at one of those
Chinese weddings then they look at this
like this look at this and you go like
that dawg
you see I'm saying we ain't got time to
[__] around do you want to [__] around
go somewhere else
this ain't Cali this ain't Jersey this
is uncle Joey's jurisdiction you
understand me and in my jurisdiction I
do I'm the Captain Kirk of the [__]
enterprise and you're the assistant to
the assistant to the assistant to the
assistant for the assistant captain I
don't want to hear no [__] stories
they laugh if you get nothing if you're
Nadine hang up now [__] cuz I'm
angry at you [__] one of your
little mothers calmly they wants to
sniff my nuts for me to come over and
read you a bedtime story get it together
you little [__]
always remember when you're dealing
underneath drugs edibles narcotics
always have water you don't want to
dehydrate you know I'm saying you eat a
couple's and if you don't drink water
you [__] kicked me shrink up in the
middle of night then you are passing out
but you're in pain when the others do we
gonna call Ghostbusters doesn't that eat
that stuff cause you really gotta bond
it with your name on it you still
haven't eaten those two [__] green
things you give me five stars
I'll give you another five more when you
finish those two green [__] things I
told you ten lucky dick if you got
plants canceling them please go on a hot
yoga tomorrow he went today he got dizzy
he broke the [__] the zip line again
it's all over they they picked him up
with the zip line he broke it right in
yoga the Maori she was going crazy the
book of white people with dirty feet in
the end through the one into it the
dirty feet was yelling and screaming
what do you guys know yeah I'm saying
what are you gonna flop and go anyway
it's time to do a Luiz Luigi type bomb
hit him you broke this Atlanta yoga you
dirty [__] he went in there was this
little jewelry Gator feet and they knew
it right off the bat they said you're
the you you one of those juveniles look
at you
let's go cut second I'm where we're
going dude can I you understand me down
my mom what I'll break that [__]
finger call the cops do not call the
ambulances if you see my eyeball popping
out and forming from the mob don't donut
just sent to the foam to the Month
Association let's do this located right
next to the 7-eleven
the poor child next to the ices mm-hmm
next to the ice is here that's a bed
come on child boy and Isis that's a
recipe for destruction
those little filthy Isis people I love
little boys they've what bang them then
they put remains up there like [__]
man on fire disgusting oh let's do this
sure can County Jail you lookin good
let's do this [__] do this [__] kind of
got something this is the one right here
this is the one right here this is the
one right here this is the one right
here
oh [__] well I did was not only gonna
put mushroom dust in here and [__]
toenail I [__] buff that I buffed out
- [__] him
I bumped out the [__] day uh nobody
call it the fungi toenail I bumped some
of that sand off the top and I put it in
there - you understand we're going deep
tonight you found me [__] around
today Jay Larson see brought one of his
station here's an open mic er you know I
need this [__] now over here please done
he's recovering don't worry about him
he's he's a little [__] boy from
down the corner of them smoked weed with
me sure you join circle because that's
the weed that killed [__] the chick
from Star Wars and trying to tell you
[__] Carrie Fisher
alright P don't smoke this [__] next
time with an empty stomach I tried to
tell you [__] then he gave it to
your mother what are you gonna do don't
people got no respect some kids got no
respect table us
what bondage Emma's alright your
probation good I don't give a [__] I
can't judge mileage Jackson
my middle name is probation is the
Voodoo Lounge a lot of people have been
walking there's a lot of people haven't
walked that so anyway give you a few
minutes leave this is [__] yeah
elbows hurt because this weed supply CBD
juices to everything
that's right does it cleaning out the
[__] cancers and the lizard meat and
all this [__] eat during the week it's
cleaning out of your system as we speak
you follow me when you get weed from the
1i Jude is how it goes down so goes down
I've been trying to tell you
[__] for years and when we
smoked something insane Posse [__] I put
some old coke slots in here and grinder
them up
you got to sauce left what's going on
that'll be good for y'all bow you one
star for each out ball there you got
Heat if you're under 18 hang up now
[__] I don't want your mother hit
me up during the week you drank Drano or
some [__] you little [__] go to
bed go to bed you [__] go read dr.
Seuss what are we doing who's up here me
all right [__] hold on one second Oh
who shot that duck [__] will
something for you from the afternoon how
old garlic shrimp it's killing the
hemorrhoids right now you know saying
killing the hemorrhoid
[Music]
boop-boop-boop I'm saying you wanna keep
[__] around
will you little [__] you friends at
Starbucks you wanna hang out with uncle
Joey huh it's up to you [__]
break out the roll of papers get the
cough medicine I don't give a [__] what
you do it's Wednesday night every man
for himself
paydays Friday I don't give you snort
antifungal medication listen you get the
bag you spray the spray in it and then
hopefully like sticky Charlie and you'll
be [__] some giggling all night what
do you want a bond everyone you ready
for nobody
that's all right listen the weave is
[Laughter]
collaboration
take me to the next whiskey Bob
the people think you're tuned in here
there's gonna be so Brock Toba people
gonna be doing [__] hot yoga listen
the only heat is the heat coming out of
my [__]
if you smell that fight your mother will
kill over you follow me this Wednesday
night [__] stuff to get your life
together
uncle joy died on the cross for you
[__] and you're sitting there
staring at me like I owe you 10 bucks
everybody's dying a [__] cross I'm
saying even hobby moisty oh [__] who
wrote a letter to Harvey Weinstein
anybody send him a postcard nothing what
the [__] kind of people you people
disgraceful
Jungian [__] Harvey Weinstein's
movies you've seen and you never sent
him a [__] dollar PayPal nothing you
[__] he's doing a go fund me
anything help him out him Burt are
looking for a [__] oven or whatever
the [__] they burn Burt needs to go [__]
me that to get a [__] barbecue grill
you believe this in this day and age a
gofundme barbecue grill that [__] no
drinking's going to his [__] cranium
you follow me he's lucky I love him that
[__] anyway what else what else
you want to know about it's getting
[__] late I suggest you do what you
got to do if you got a date
go wash your helmet and put some
vaseline on your finger it's Wednesday
night somebody's gettin up the [__]
muffler says who says me [__] when
I was young and handsome I'd be banging
somebody on the muffler on Wednesday
night it's ladies night you follow me 50
cents drinks in other words it's like
Burger King have it your way
anywhere you bad [__] sure you
gotta take vaseline on your finger the
[__] gotta people you just don't touch
nobody I'm sayin just just leave your
hand your left hand out like that we get
blocking something you never went out
with Vaseline on your fingers what type
of people are you savages anyway
youtube.com slash seats last Joey Diaz
that's the place to be [__] about ten
minutes we'll do a couple more bonnets
we ain't going nowhere overly finishes
the stache it
he's over there doing this
if this is that's the point
that's the put somebody posted a video
today it's not his face did you see that
leading out of space and they show
what's his name is here and he's playing
the drums to all the music and Leah's
highest pluck and he's like and this
guy's hand is going like this
he's like always [__] crazy when I
saw it today I died the [__] laughs
Ali go to youtube right now
and look for Lee and out of space is it
good that's that what else you want you
want information I got no information
who was the accomplice that the Vegas
shooter had Corey Bravo and calm down we
he's over there scratching his head
looking at documentaries on Netflix he's
pressing in Vegas shooter nuts coming up
he's frustrating who loves you
[__] more than for Joey
nobody Omaha get your [__] together
clean up the [__] install uncle Joey's
coming and then from there we go
straight for the New York Comedy
Festival got them November 10th and 11th
get your [__] together
November 9th with Ari up in Brooklyn
telling some [__] stories it's some
[__] hobo palace is up like that
besides that you know I love your
[__] I got you who wants to do
a bond him one more what do you think
should we do this whole [__] thing
right now I'm in the mood
Lee [__] do we do usually do what we do
is we'll take that liquid ass there we
go sprinkling on the [__] bud we'll
let it art ee tit that's the next move
for New Year's Eve we're gonna do a
podcast we're gonna eat a bun with
[__] acid on it nobody's ever done
that you understand me not even
what's-his-name what's the guy who does
the records
you know whatever the [__] is nameless I
don't I got tired I remember right now
you want a member you wanna you want to
play Japanese go go go call grandpa
right I think got time for this [__]
right now with a different [__]
planet you [__]
let's smokes under this leave I'll do
one of these they went through the
toenail again the toenail was [__]
delicious J myself you'll know what
you're missing jail I see you eat all
the edibles you should blame it in the
playing game so we check your pockets
I'll get the dog to come over here
well that's a start that that's got
[__] sand and cement both of the good
ones right there those are the good ones
when they get dirty yeah take it some of
the we from the floor what's up dog
how's that out of a dog oh [__]
this is least favorite song we do
edibles right here
you don't get into that [__] stand
rafi me for like my 45th birthday he
gave me that [__] in that that CD like
I put my ipod to charge [__]
tremendously
I just remembered it when I look
unbelievable well outs [__] I
got nothin else for you
Lee you ready for fun let's do this [__]
let's do this [__] we're not to know is
good so I smoked bisa TKO never killed
nobody
once I show on TV people love this House
of Pain where there's Kevin Spacey this
is [__] house of butts
what's the points at Dodgers score will
you check yeah juice is real good Berlin
that was pitch the knocking at the door
knocking on the door let's do this I'm
the oddball Bush let's do this [__] here
we go that's the one that's the one
that's the one we say oh [__] look at
them like a [__] doctor
that's his shaft there's somebody blue
with the statement that various Jedi
said wha
now we'll do another one of the total of
a second the toenail is [__]
tremendous yeah what happened what
happened what happened I hear things
falling I hear Chinese people crying
that means it's a good time when you
hear Chinese people crying you're about
to have a good time [__]
somebody got their spare rib stone what
the [__] you think you're dealing on
some novice I suggest you get you
[__] eat two sandwiches before you
come on this periscope again you
understand me I don't wanna know a
McCoy's I'm just [__] periscope no
more I'm gonna start doing a background
check they should have done a background
check on Columbus but I'm gonna do one
now cuz that's how I roll [__]
start Monday you need like a twenty two
bong at minimum to come on it's like a
table at Vegas right or wrong we ain't
got time to play games that you [__]
amateurs and they ain't people either
you get down or you're [__] getting
down we think of that man
[Music]
remember hydration is the key to medical
marijuana and with that I bid you a felt
what is it I do that's what it is I bid
you a farewell adieu that's how I roll
that's my speechwriter right here
[__] anyway if you don't come
to the ice out Saturday sold I
understand but the following week we're
over there in Omaha Nebraska then the
following week it's me and Dean Dale
Rizzi I got some comedy club don't look
don't come to me Joey then dump I'm
[__] telling you now I'm telling you
now [__] okay look I believe he's
[__] pale he told me his blood
pressure is the sponsor other spots are
already responsible your beers I'm
saying the weed works weed works your
logic to none you allergic to [__]
hummus that's what you need to be
allergic to that [__] that's killing
America anyway I love you [__]
stay black
I'll see you later have a good time
youtube.com slash c / Joey beers your
buddies here sucks and you [__] together